and welcome to punch-drunk sportswear
winners win
look at this crew of happiness right
here everybody smiling it's a special
show we got professional fighter in
studio from his big fight in Vegas Rhino
Neil everybody hey guys thanks for
having me Ryan congratulations on a
successful weekend even though you
didn't get the call it was a great show
you guys put up historic numbers on
ellis mania more people watched it over
the internet than any before or ever how
many times have they done that by the
way 50th this was the 15th one alright
yeah so 15 because I know he's like a
little he's like I don't know if I'm
gonna do it anymore and then he seemed
overly excited when he would watch yeah
yeah he was I mean look I'm just glad
that the fight didn't wasn't like just a
[ __ ] show of just amateurism fine I mean
it was but it was also like two guys who
were like who had some [ __ ] skin in
the game well you guys trying their best
to do so I mean I've seen some really
bad amateur fights and I this ranks just
slightly above that it was it was there
were some fun fights here you tell some
people came with skill sets yeah people
just showed up there is a weird kind of
dynamic between a hot track of a woman
is versus her fighting skills well first
of all let's just say this and I mean
this from the bottom of my heart please
any woman willing to take a punch live
on television I find that quite
attractive yeah I'm not gonna lie if
you're if you're if you're like hey I'm
hot but I also you know I mean I like to
get my teeth out what do you mean what
do you mean like to get my teeth chip
trying to say that these women you know
that are taking punches kudos and I
think we need to see some more of that
with ladies we need to see some more of
that ladies
now the girl the fairy girl who had
legit skills was pretty hot chick that
was tearing it off he was probably the
most technical of yeah literally
everybody yeah and she was tied up Kyle
Kingsbury yeah and and you too and the
last who fights she was the most
technical by far yeah absolutely
by I mean like she was using she was
using combos stick move head movement
slipping yeah this girl was a good
fighter too and she went up against the
ferry and I just like nobody yeah what
like I don't know if you guys notice but
I think Ellis is pretty much bisexual so
he puts out a [ __ ] guy in a thong
yeah glory holes fix his dicks through
there yeah so he's into all this by the
way Michael Bisping is much bigger than
you would think from 185 he's huge yeah
yeah I was taller than him though I was
hot though on the walk to the weigh-in I
was walking right behind him so I went
up to him and I was like hey and he just
kinda was like hey just thought I was a
fan and blew you off you look like a
[ __ ] idiot
yeah I was like hey I'm actually Ryan
O'Neal and I think uh dressed with the
[ __ ] sunscreen oh yeah by the way I
this is one of my favorite people on the
planet right here
thick Canadian porn star girl on the
floor oh yeah by the way at some point I
just decided to go in the ring there is
no security so I just started taking
between fighting like Sam's in there
with strippers taking photos [ __ ] Sam
had access to everything I see him come
out of Ellis's [ __ ] dressing room
with a sandwich I was like dude get me a
sandwich I got my wishes I was taking
pictures with her I was doing [ __ ]
Instagram stories loading things just
one chicks like hey you can't go away so
just went the other way nobody said
anything it's a very loose ship yeah are
you were walking into everybody's
dressing yeah I was I was giving
everybody just didn't want anybody to
get hurt
that was my biggest I was the whole
other direction I'm like I hope
everybody gets hurt in this goddamn
hey Jason you got any dates how the
gates got anywhere anyone can see yeah
um oh yeah I got a big fantasy football
draft later on this afternoon so get
ready for that what are you drafting
which one my league women buddies back
home I'd say one more loser kills
himself
that is where loser kills himself but
guess what I might throw the league just
to kill myself because I'm just too good
at fantasy and you guys were all
seriously
let's see I will be of course I'll be at
the big and I believe you're going to be
there as well
the all things comedy fest old yeah well
they think I'm gonna be there I don't
know I haven't gotten my official invite
last year was pretty fun I remember I
went to a pool party and I think I'm the
only person there it's youssef and it's
you know Eric the manager from the
common store yeah they're sitting there
and I say hi to them and I go are we the
only ones here and they point to the
pool I turn on and look in the pool and
it's you and Dennis are in the pool as
vuela is a completely fully dressed Doug
Stanhope in a suit in the pool it's not
to his waist
he's bad I like one o'clock in the
afternoon I'm like oh it's just you
three bozos in the pool don't you guys
want to go to the pool I was like yeah I
took my clothes off I didn't know where
is it so I'll be there for that let's
see I'll be at doing a gig downtown
tomorrow for my good friend Jackie
Gold's birthday whiskey and donuts I'm
doing that tomorrow and I was at the
Comedy Store on Sunday so you missed
that [ __ ] I did actually crush it Ryan
you got any gigs you want to tell us
about some fun stuff you're doing I'll
just be at the comedy store sometime
this week that's a you should be there
at least once a week and hopefully I'll
be at the all things comedy festival oh
I hope so too
your podcast is literally blowing up
people are talking about it constantly
wait were you hearing this everybody's
just on the streets were you at Ralph's
it's like every aisle you go down to
having some weird kind of Fight Club
everybody's just like you in on at you
in on it you
and everybody's in on it all right I
like to hear I like that the kids are
talking ah fight nanny are you gonna be
anywhere getting maybe pregnant again or
anything like that
oh she's absolutely showing up the
streak is back on we sold it out again I
was getting nervous where is this at the
the dojo the comedy show oh oh Jesus
yeah dude those [ __ ] lineups are
stacked
yeah I'm have to start figuring some
stuff out cuz a lot of people keep doing
the same lineup so it's getting harder
and harder so you gotta kind of figure
it out yeah I like to put be putting up
more people get a different kind of
lineup it's just hard it's [ __ ] 350
370 it's like I'd love to do a show of
us and then we could do 20 people and
just be like in deep space you know I'm
saying yeah you ever done the main room
and nobody's there like and you're geo a
time I do to me
I like those late-night spots though I
do like those like I so uh tonight sold
out I will be September 5th
it is the tinfoil hat comedy night Eddie
Bravo feel Vaughn in the belly room
that's almost sold out so grab your
tickets now and then and oh [ __ ] I
forgot
it's Eddie Bravo Theo von Rhine Davison
hey Ron will be there too just [ __ ] on
all of our dreams
that's what's gonna do if you come in
and just basically explain to us why
everything we just talked about is not
true that is correct it's [ __ ] great
and then September 14th and 15th I am at
the I'm at the the corner comedy club in
Niagara Falls grab your tickets now oh
[ __ ] and then October 12th we're at Tim
fauxhawk comedy night me Eddie Bravo
Ryan Davis at the Philly punchline and
in October 14th this Syracuse funny bone
so grab those tickets
especially Syracuse I can't have an
empty room in my own backyard
so thank you guys um what's the deal
with your ATC sage get that figured out
yet no I'm gonna talk to her again today
and try to lock that down Sam real in
the
memo from my check anal I just want you
all to know cuz that's not gonna be
humiliating to the body just change it
to a Mele Jason's he's got a little fun
too there you go
it's mine's always the same thing but
[ __ ] sometimes he puts like you know
sucking [ __ ] or you know I've never had
a personal check from him so this is a
new tree oh yeah I'll take that all day
so Ryan let's go through the fight do
you mind talking about no not at all man
I you know what I did it and you get
Greg I'm I'm proud of it I should I mean
it was mine to lose in the third and I
let it go and I think responses so
here's the thing dude let's start off
first of all how did the walkout feel so
so there was no time frame about any of
this what do you mean like I nobody told
me we were supposed to fight at 9:45
then they came in and be like we're
delayed by about 40 minutes yeah okay
well yeah that was I want to start my
warm-up about 20 minutes before he was
really behind and then about 10 minutes
later they go hey yeah you're coming out
in five minutes so real so it was 40
minutes then it's five minutes yeah so
then they didn't give you a list of the
fights because the fights followed
exactly how the Lydia's fate but they
said they were behind somebody had told
us that their bike episode they got like
a TV in the back this wasn't like a UFC
no we could have watched with after a
while I had like turn off the TV it's
giving me [ __ ] anxiety on the
broadcast they kept saying that they
were like an hour behind is that what
they were saying yeah yeah so that's
what they thought and then it turns out
that they were actually right on time
and so um also my coach was out there
and he was fighting him one of the
fights before hello your coach was so
your coach coach or is he just for the
night he was my coach for like the last
five weeks like I met with him one an
hour to an hour and a half every Monday
and then I saw him at Saxons Muay Thai
and then we would spar and we would you
know [ __ ] around and do yeah [ __ ] yeah
so for like the last five weeks because
up until that point I couldn't get an
MMA gym that would [ __ ] train me
because everyone was like you need to
have three months of jiu-jitsu or it was
like a [ __ ] class that was catering
to like an all-around MMA but I wanted
like me sprawling and brawling cuz I
knew I wasn't gonna [ __ ] learn
jujitsu in that amount of time so I had
to go with my strength which was gonna
be kicking and [ __ ] you know
sprawling right kicking in sprawling
yeah so I had a week's worth of
wrestling training and then the rest was
all Muay Thai at the yard for two months
and then my last month was how much the
boxing did you did you study I started
doing boxing with Eddie five weeks
beforehand so the before that it was
just all Muay Thai and I was basically
training myself like I was fighting some
I thought if at the yard I would find
some MMA guys because they don't have an
MMA program they just do Muay Thai but I
thought there's enough MMA guys to train
there but then I realized dude it's all
like Mickey Gaul Edward yeah like all
these deals they're all getting are
gonna real yeah these guys not gonna
train with right right right right
so then I was just working on striking
and conditioning but then you end up
with a [ __ ] you know a ton of issues
multiple [ __ ] bruised ribs same
weight and and I've just another's
excuses like Luis had the same [ __ ] his
[ __ ] shoulder popped out his hand was
all [ __ ] up he had rib I already broke
his hand his hand looked [ __ ] gnarly
my favorite part of the night was Kim
Condon talking about how they did it we
did it I'm like you did nothing you did
nothing
you drained his ball sack occasionally
that's and you got a free trip out to
Vegas
what are you talking about know what I
was trying to find for the weigh-in I
wanted to have one of those never Kim
cognate spooby shirts yeah I wanted to
wear that - the way it but I couldn't
[ __ ] find him you should have brought
out Sarah wine jack and used her bra her
out right ah so you you're walking out
you're watching the fights it's kind of
fun so the two guys in my corner my
brother-in-law and then my my fiance's
brother-in-law's a buddy of mine but now
what kind of fighting experience do
these guys have so my the guy from
Fresno he was a d1 wrestler
in college so he I worked with him for a
couple hours
to trade for it right I'd be right on
the ground right like you've got good
instincts yeah and you seem like you
know you can get up and he's like I'm
not that worried about on the ground so
it's like all right got the wrestling
out of the way I'm good to go
so I knew the whole strategy here was
just a cheap [ __ ] leg kick and throw
that jab that was like what we worked on
the whole [ __ ] five weeks yeah what
exactly did happen to the headgear I
don't know man his headgear I think
broke that's what it looked like and
then they just took my headgear off I
can't believe you didn't agree to that I
heard my mind go no hey Ellis is like
[ __ ] the headgear and then I was like
that's crazy
yeah should not be on no one really
consulted with me on my especially when
you're in or Luis Gomez will hear this
use this as a reason to start a war with
us but I do believe that that is uh that
is the one part of the fight I think
just didn't go well yeah I think you
said yes so no I was in better shape
three weeks ago well you would obviously
eaten like fish went Harden well no arms
above Fame right so my my right away
you're in great shape compared to
anybody here at this moment but my I was
in way better shape I'm us so my right
rib two weeks before the fight got
[ __ ] caved in by two hard knees and a
clinch and so after that I got I
couldn't do a whole lot not at this
point
loose Gomez is purely using [ __ ]
strength and he's just [ __ ] moving
for I I didn't realize how thick his
legs were till I was [ __ ] kicking him
and I was like - those things are
[ __ ] sweet shrugs yeah so here he
catches me and I was like and so me my
whole goal here was just to tie up and
have him stand us up yeah yeah yeah high
up and the opposite of that happen he
did keep it on the ground and then
removed your headgear I'm just like
holding on to him for dear life I was
like all right he's gonna stand us up
cuz even Ellis told me if there's
nothing going on the ground i'ma stand
you guys were you nervous about
takedowns like did you think you might
catch it was my greatest fear being
mounted but since it happened to the
first round after that I had no more
from your nice
oh well I I heard they were like this is
what you wanted Louis and he I saw the
look at his eye and [ __ ] just sheer
excitement well do what they don't ever
I think even said something to me I
think he said something to me like
you're [ __ ] dead now or something I've
thought it that's what I think I heard
in my head look really excited some sort
of professional fire he's a nice guy I
met him before the rodeo Milt yeah he's
a good guy but you know beforehand he
goes look I've only ref boxing matches I
haven't ref and then they so he's like
but he's a super good guy and he's nice
guy but I think we're who you are if a
guy is in on the ground right yeah if
he's on the ground I just hey you take
his headgear off this is what I thought
you were done no I knew I wasn't cuz I
had his arm I knew I had his arm trapped
I had his left arm trapped right there
oh that's gotta hurt and I knew that I
could take some hits but I knew I had
his arm he wouldn't get me a real name
thank god you're a heck dude you know
because you're hick background allowed
you to get through those punches dude I
knew I wasn't gonna get knocked out I've
been hit pretty hard before and it's
never really faced me and these are
sights but some of these punches I was
seeing like a flash oh dude oh the crowd
went nuts at that moment this is
basically two dudes who have no [ __ ]
jujitsu going at it right now this was
the best Gomez xscape there yeah dude I
hear everyone was like going look gasps
I wasn't wearing it here I go yes I was
moment where I might if Luis Gomez had
any kind yes of [ __ ] jujitsu training
he could have pulled the leg down and
gotten you in the triangle maybe once he
grabbed my ankle I was but I was trying
to posture up but his [ __ ] legs are
heaviest you had him set up for a Boston
Crab there I'm really disappointed
you also had a nice reverse cowgirl girl
you are spent you are spent at this
point fighting oh dude without a doubt
he's sweet innit like I think he told me
he thought he was around 2:15 and I was
about 186 pounds so I like right here
Eddie yeah he's so much a 40 pound
difference he's like ah right dude
he's exhausted you're like I'm exhausted
Eddie even said he's like who's not
gonna try to take you down again he's
too [ __ ] tired he's thinking got it
I'm sitting him they're not even sitting
them all he's trying to play it up for
the judges so how would you give that
round Ryan I mean that was he won that
round clearly but it wasn't like a 10-8
round because i [ __ ] reversed it and
I had like why would it be you know I
would agree with that so and you know
he's getting some I have that I have him
up ten nine absolutely no he definitely
took that round for sure I feel like and
listen dude hindsight's forty twenty
twenty or forty forty whatever you want
to say aha inside forty forty then we
name this episode hindsight's forty okay
at what point do you go I got to start
boxing this guy had no point at every
point but my arms were [ __ ] my good
daddy that is the big even looking back
in that third round I go dude wide one
my throwing but then in my head I was
trying to [ __ ] it you're like row row my
art like when your arms get laid out on
the ground like that like all the blood
goes and you just [ __ ] spaghetti and
you're just trying to get a little rest
like just buy some time yeah
so here I said a little so I have a
little bit of a flurry here which won me
the round uh but in that last round I
was just [ __ ] trying to survive to
you know no I did Carney cardio for
trading did you do a lot of cardio I did
yeah the problem is all that was a good
punch there was a good punch that was
like oh man he caught you and of course
he used that as like some weird kind of
drawing they took that moment I know I
know but I was like so I couldn't run
after so the first month I had been
running and I started getting shin
splints so bad that I was out for about
a week yeah DJ go I think that maybe
you're not supposed to go full bore into
like a heart
while guided so I just wet balls let you
know you literally trained more than
anybody else outside of probably Ellis
and cot I don't even think I oh that had
to hurt right there yeah I know I know
mystery I mean gomez was yeah you two
did out of doubt what everybody else
just showed up yes nobody's taking a
Syria you two were the first ones to
take it serious I think I wear my
exhaustion a little bit better than he
did at one point also I didn't I can't
oh yeah well he's open because he I
don't have my glasses or any contact so
you're that blind right now yet my
prescriptions like I'm about a negative
five you're like rody negative five are
you forty or forty forty uh no I think
I'm twenty five hundred right now you're
both looking busy not doing anything
maybe both throwing out punches oh but
he's connecting but you're looking busy
which is great which is great it's dude
I just had to keep that hand out there
are is so funny because our he's like I
want five five-minute rounds do - no way
no are you kidding me I would have gone
deep Elmo would have been better if it
was one minute it's like firing it wrong
he's just so stupid
Ari's gonna [ __ ] on you so hard it's
gonna blow I don't dude I be honest with
you anyone that shits on me that didn't
have doesn't have the balls to go in and
get killed
of course dude I had guys that came up
to me after this who was like dude I
used to train MMA I don't know how the
[ __ ] you got out of that goddamn full
mount with a really impressive 50 pounds
whaling on you so I was like [ __ ] it was
all worth it just for that moment to
prove to myself well because I wasn't
you know what he was doing either yes
that's the blessing yeah
you know I mean when you're doing acid
like a week and a month and a half
before this now is there with these look
nothing's really happening not saying
it's not go but it's like stay active
state that round could go either way I
will give
you I will give it to you but I think it
go him but I'm gonna give it to you so
and they even go it's 1:1 yeah I think I
eked it out there yeah yeah he talked I
heard him I could held it in the middle
of zero what kind of dialogue are you
guys having any dialogue during during
when your dialogue in the third round he
yells at me no no Luis is Jelena Allen
from across its like a fighter come on
or a trainer with local gyms and he
would show up and if one guy was like
destroying the other guy in a fight he
would come up and just be like boom and
you just hit him oh jeez Oh Elvis yeah
he's great she's getting she's so young
but she's getting thick there's gonna be
a fat right there's gonna be a fat
moment but right now it is perfect Sam
Tripoli right there
yeah dude boom bouncing balls enjoying
life
by the way Eddie Jackson great [ __ ]
great coach they cut to a stripper all
those tripley right behind the surfer
Paul on his phone on his phone right
behind his stripper pole all right so
what's your mindset right now stop it
let's get into this what is this right
here I'm like dude I got to throw my
hands I gotta [ __ ] survive this [ __ ]
I got a I got to find a way to win this
round yeah what is by the way that
you're doing great you feel good guy
this guy now when he's doing this what
do you think's going what's going
through your head he's putting on a show
no I don't care I know he's tired like I
none of this affected me like I none of
it affected me come on
yes stop talking stop resting and get
back to the [ __ ] course we he's like
Vince McMahon and then he comes up and
he does nothing Elvis is just hanging
out I would love if you could do that in
any real sizes where yeah this is where
I was like [ __ ] so this is where I was
trying to throw a handsome he was
clocking me yeah you yeah he was hype it
was a minute round right no three yeah
it's mo there were three minutes yeah
three three-minute rounds I'm impressed
it's so hard dude so this is where I was
like I'm gonna go find that rib that's
broke
but it was the wrong side boom look at
that you look my hands are [ __ ] but like
they're slow you know but I was pushing
him back and I didn't realize it like I
should have just let him [ __ ] fly
this looks like some special cops versus
[ __ ] cons it does where so like the
sheriff or the neighbourhood like this
is all Hart here yeah yeah he had enough
in those punches to get going and that's
see that's where I threw and then I got
[ __ ] wife you countered you hard yeah
just moving it just [ __ ] strength at
this point what what what was the mo na
this by like I don't I don't remember
all the time and people were something
did I don't even know or that his tape
came off or something the guy who
wrapped my hands he's like this is the
shittiest hand wrapping job I've ever
done he's like I feel like Lewis is
getting wrapped by a UFC champion next
door but this is [ __ ] this is shitty
I go yeah did you shut the [ __ ] up I'll
wrap my own hands there I was like why
would you tell me that
who is it your cousin your brother some
dude nice your grandpa that was at the
after-party woman my future brother
that's the best that's the best this man
didn't even know what he was doing no
and I was like dude I would just wrap
them myself by the way I asked for more
wrapping cuz my right hands [ __ ] up
and he's like he ran out of tape because
that's all the gauze I have man your
friends always subdue to work for hours
yeah this sounds so unorganized it does
have a completely chaotic here's the one
moment that I should have capitalized on
more when I get him in that clinch and I
throw a knee I should have just unloaded
a barrage of knees in there it's good
it's towards the end of the fight at the
end of this what was the most hurt you
worded what I wish they would have done
is also let you guys come out oh yeah
you guys I wasn't there I wasn't ever
hurt neccessity you know what I mean
yeah like I as long as I just step back
and reset you don't look like you might
go at all I was you know one thing I
wanted to do was get punched - just
[ __ ] see what I could handle yeah
and on the ground - he's [ __ ] he
wailing somebody on the ground but yeah
those teeps I stopped doing the teeps
after he caught him and I should have
just kept him [ __ ] throwing him in
there
yeah well obvious some reason you can
throw a kick but you can't throw a punch
isn't that weird dude it's because my
default is kicking okay cuz you
Taekwondo yeah but that I quit I was
like 20 years ago and I didn't ever do
anything after like age 19 it's just you
know what you're great a young age of
whatever it's like rest is it in you a
little bit like I took Tai box in my
whole life or like cha-ching couldn't oh
and JKD
you know and then I took Thai boxing
forever on and off you know but I could
throw punches and I could yeah my
strength was always the kicking and so I
I mean look I thought you were nicer
afterwards he's someone in his corner
gave you water that's very nice and
you're such a good sport by the way I
think after when you found out he won
yeah his his coaches were [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] great guys they were
really cool man those guys were all
super cool by the way if he lost he had
the suck big J's dick he had every
reason to power through that last
problem I don't know why people had me
as if I had a black belt in Taekwondo
when I was like 19 you really hyper self
up though I was like why do I hate
anybody yeah you're like dude you were
like I gotta leave here I have to go
[ __ ] run him out like we really had
someone that I hate Muay Thai for five
months when I was 33 and then I got back
into training three months ago you're
really good at it like I was like he's
got this no like questions asked you're
really also a lot of it was masking like
injuries that like yeah if you talked to
my fiancee she'll be like dude like
there was days I'm just laying on the
couch I couldn't [ __ ] move
dude I would train the next day after
being in that much pain
usually the neck then I'd be alright it
was just like I was training too much
cuz I didn't have any guidance and then
I would over train and then I'd have to
like lay on the couch for two days and
then I'd be fine I'll be like oh nothing
yes anymore but yeah the shin splints
took me out for a week rib injury took
me out for ten days in the beginning
just went to a Thai class and just a cut
Thai class and sparred
that's what I did
you were like looking for like a sensei
in a [ __ ] in a dojo and in some sort
of I want him MA I didn't even know they
had bad no I would have fought somebody
I didn't know either
I wanted a belt so bad did everybody
that one get a belt
yeah every fact there was a belt Oh mom
fell so badly at the same time dude I
looked at it like I'm 40 years old I
[ __ ] did this I survived it I didn't
look I didn't get absolutely destroyed
you did great I got beat and then I was
like you know what it's a [ __ ] win
somebody that I was taught a member who
said it but they were like this looks
like like two old guys fighting I go it
is to me what it is
it's 2:40 are all telling you like we
didn't sell it as anything other this is
like our aunt first amateur fight ever
yeah secret listen dude if you put like
a Chuck Liddell like they're got that
Chuck Liddell Tito Ortiz yeah that's
give me two old guys fighting yeah it's
gonna be slower that was creepy
yeah so this is the weirdest fight right
so these guys have to go and hit this
thing that you're coach right yeah Eddie
yeah and he's Eddie's uh it was a pro
boxer yeah Pro moita or pro MMA guy was
he always fighting in this competition
yeah he's been with he's like Ellis's go
to dry off on this [ __ ] guy do by the
way I've seen this guy spar Elvis he is
[ __ ] real like that two days your
coach is the only person without a
helmet what's happening that imagine
because dude he gets no one's gonna hit
him hit him hard enough to make him
their right away Eddie's so good that he
can like what he'll pull it back like
don't hurt these are the guys in blue
just regular people know what they're
doing Elvis guides is the head movement
he doesn't even have to [ __ ] a block
imagine being a bouncer so the guys were
just boxing regular boxing people know
the guys in blue are just like truck
drivers yeah I can be waiters at any
fighting professionals yeah oh that's
right of all the guys like me Eddie just
knock that dudes out of all the guys
like I wouldn't want to fight the Elvis
guy
Eddie Elisa's like dude I'll knock you
down but I'm not gonna back you out but
I feel like Elvis if you hit him hard he
would [ __ ] come back by the way that
really gives shake is just whaling on
his [ __ ] this poor girl is trying to hit
this thing and this black chick it's
just lighting her up the whole time
she's a pro - I think herself she had
some sort of official training like what
it was a girl-on-girl one of them was
like a legit something yeah I mean like
dude it sucks barely trying to and it's
just like also affect I think the
musical chairs fight was the one I was
most emotionally invested in there's
like eight of those you because when you
- three of them green some of people
have to fight time at like three in a
row that's what happen to you
it sucks it's so that's really what
their I am look at me just hanging out
in the middle of the Ring triply holding
a [ __ ] ball so did you talk to
Bisbing after yeah I mean I talked to
him right there I talked to him there
and I was like hey man I didn't mean to
disrespect the sport of MMA yeah cuz I
was like mad at how you were dressed
yeah your way I thought I think he
thought I didn't train at all but then I
think I want him over because it was
like oh this guy didn't quit he could
have quit yeah if it's like some shitty
amateur fight maybe the guy just would
have just been like I tap out what he's
getting punched but he [ __ ] turned it
over and he really wanted to do this so
afterwards he's like great fight man
that's a cool yeah he's always been like
I met him a couple times cuz he's always
with Gomez night real nice guy
you wouldn't think and then like the
other day I was in like a YouTube rabbit
hole you know I have like MMA fights and
like 1:00 in the morning them was like a
the top 10 like MMA fights that happen
outside of the Octagon unit I mean which
is mostly like on the tough show and
things like that were people getting
scraps and then I one of them was like
MMA bullies that get what's coming to
him whenever and it was when Henderson
knocked him out yeah
I forgot what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you was
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I used to not like him because of that
bulimia to last couple years I've like
think he's very entertaining yeah yeah
yeah Louis are like good like because
they're both great [ __ ] talk yeah yeah
they're great [ __ ] I like their podcast
whoo I know Jeff told you I would listen
to likes yeah I know I appreciate that
now I like it I'm like this being funny
yeah he's always been a polarizing
figure I know he's been funny bike who
else was uh I forgot Josh Koscheck what
a [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy was yeah
real men when I think that was like just
I think that was real we're visiting was
just like yeah we're going to work yeah
yeah yeah Bisbing was i hamming it up
almost like i McGregor's style
yeah and kasich was just an actual dick
yeah like nobody liked him you know I
mean the problem when you talk that
amount of shih tzus though when you get
beat everybody's just [ __ ] cheering
them yeah like when Nate beat Conor and
we were all dying in Worcester voices oh
yeah I'll never forget that that was a
bad that was the best by the way this
fight here with Kyle Kings Kings Barry
is [ __ ] huge yeah that's how he's
dressed like the whole weekend and even
have a fanny pack on it he would have
like just that in a fanny pack was there
an after party you had to go to yeah
there was it was like a dominatrix no
like l.j smells didn't show up till
after I left cuz he was uh I think he
was hurting from some of these shots
that he took from this and then Louis
wasn't there well it would be because he
was his hand was all [ __ ] up and stuff
hospital or she just dealing with like a
broken hand I do when I saw him the next
day is had like the bone right here on
his hand was just [ __ ] I mean it was
you know like
domina's wrist gnarly and he said he had
had problems going in I mean so this
hand so this knuckle won't go down like
this finger won't go down and tell I
[ __ ] hit I have to pound it in like I
put my glove on and I have to [ __ ]
basically pound it down crazy so I mean
we all we all came into that fight the
gloves you were using seemed awkward to
me yes they didn't seem like standard
MMA they were seven ounce instead of
four and they weren't broken it's
actually the gloves that you
on the Ultimate Fighter okay so but they
weren't they weren't broken in at all
and that was kind of a pain in the ass
uh-huh they were very stiff yeah it was
very it was making a fist required much
more pressure than you know because
obviously they were [ __ ] literally
fresh out of the plastic it'd be
interesting to see and I'm going to say
a big shout out to our good friends at
bet DSi as always thank you to everybody
that put money on this fight a lot of
people put money on this fight they had
the actual odds enough people were
gambling on it that di was actually
changed throughout the week yeah I was
shot it was weird
I think maybe I just sold sold it but
yeah I mean that I was the favorite yeah
you started a favor and then you ended a
little bit of an underdog but so thank
you to everybody that did that and thank
you to bet DSi how cool it was it for
them to even do that real action on that
and then so everybody feel free to go
there use the code punch 25 and that'd
get you 25 free bucks to gamble with at
our good friends at bet DSi so thank you
to them for putting all that together
and hopefully we'll do more fun stuff
like that throughout the time throughout
the year and when something else comes
up but right now it's great time
football is about to start
baseball is hot as [ __ ] I went to a
baseball game in Boston Aaron and I was
like I have to talk to Aaron about this
oh nice nice nice what is the baseball
season
what does it start we got about two two
months left of it two months left of it
over yeah we're getting there's like
what do they call the last World Series
playoffs that's basketball my mom was
jealous cuz baby Barb gets to go to
Fenway Park and she doesn't do you put
her in like a cage no kids are like
getting hit with his dad got his tickets
that were behind the net like right yeah
we were there and she slept through the
whole thing so we kept sending him on
video like this if a foul ball is coming
at you just hold up the baby to stop you
shoot the ball let her catch her first
foul ball with her face
didn't a baby get hit that's a Jeff I
was like I remember that from what a
news yeah you can't sue them because it
says on the tickets are not responsible
for any of that sure they don't know
they don't pay any we don't pay anything
here here's a hot dog I went to Fenway
are you proud of me I want to I mean
I've been here I'd like to get rich
enough to just go to one game in every
Park yeah that'd be cool for the my
buddies did that for the whole see if
you've seen that real sports on the guy
who catches the foul yeah I was just
talking about that the other day with
somebody that's interesting you brought
that up and he goes to basic that's
basically what he does he now for like
500 pounds he has thousands of balls
yeah yeah he catches like a couple of
every game he'll teach you how to fun
yeah it's like 500 bucks to take his
class what everybody guarantees you you
will catch balls yeah that's the
weirdest niche ever yeah I know yeah and
most of them are like batting practice
oh is that what there you go like he
gets it he gets a lot during batting
practice and then like some during the
game he's like he's like a dick because
he people hate him cuz he'll like reach
out there well he'll run up and like
when I like catch it right in front of
my head fielder or an outfielder could
have caught it but he's like [ __ ]
dangling off the edge uh-huh well that's
the whole thing it's like you get to
this thing right where you're like okay
I love this sport I've been going
forever I've never caught a ball in my
life
ball comes your way and there was a give
it to the kid and you're like I've been
paying for this ticket for years [ __ ]
thing but if you're this dude used to
literally caught thousands of balls he's
taking it away from the kids he's
running over there oh yeah he's such
weirdos I love baseball dude I love it
really I used to hate it I just love it
really I can't take I just love it dude
now watch any sports right i watch I
love glory kickboxing chicken chicks
[ __ ] tobacco I love watching chicks
[ __ ] yeah oh you and I watch the same
stuff no actually I don't even like to
roll on girl
[ __ ] baby black guys one chick
anyways I'm Owens only it's got to be
Samoan point all those balls oh there's
not enough
mom porn out there it's true dude
they're keeping them out of the industry
it's so Fossum oh and restless like
you've searched for it and you're like
no there really is times you search for
everything you got to find those deep
this guy you think this guy brings
chicks back oh and look look at my balls
so many balls Skype rings nobody back
then no absolutely not
look at all these [ __ ] balls bro this
is not impressive to anybody but this
guy yeah got him no Brian come baba
Aaron who loves stuffed crust pizza even
Bryant Gumbel wasn't thrilled with this
yeah what does he do with all these
balls you know like and reels for a
second but then Bryant Gumbel has his
wrap up it's so [ __ ] overproduce he
seems like such a [ __ ]
yeah and then so like I mean he's
executive producer the show's reacts
like this just spontaneously happened
and then at the end of it let's say you
do this whole piece on this guy and that
was the Balch Scott then he has glasses
and he has like his nose like I'm just
gonna write down some thoughts during
this piece know how much money can he
make doing anyway no it's about yeah you
had to sign off on all of this I loved
his final thoughts though one of them
woods once about dumping Gatorade on the
winning team coach and how it should
stop anyway he's cool to hang out with
no way his anyway so no I know exactly
once
throw some porn on who his brothers got
to be pretty cool his brothers actually
way cooler than him like I'm not destroy
us in a notorious [ __ ] yes yeah he
reeks of a reeks of it yeah he's like
moving on you know I'd black yeah I'm
moving on I had a krysta black manager
on my column the guy used to Matt Chris
Burns and he's always like the
light-skinned black guys are always the
most militant always the most militant
right like mmm that's a said Malcolm X
is like light-skinned as a [ __ ]
is he yeah all the black-and-white
photos look extra black yeah he's like
militant right Martin Luther King right
skeleton Farrakhan you know his
kids stated our motel in Indiana right
before they closed it down and my dad
brought his kid a bunch of beer
evidently he was hiding out from the law
bear Oh dad gave him a case to hide a
kid he's like I'm go to the liquor store
you want anything
the guy's like way out take some hi to
kids so my dad dropped it off in his
[ __ ] that's funny
he was bringing all aged right driving
in those [ __ ] Hummers and I hate all
that Farrakhan money if you think he's
light-skinned Martin Luther King
light-skinned dark-skinned I would
medium medium skin like you wouldn't you
draw Martin I wouldn't consider that be
social I don't consider that be okay be
real home Martin Luther King can you
drive through Monrovia with him mad a
t-shirt why isn't that a t-shirt dude
come on I have given a favor and we've
got a punch-drunk come on man
that would sell million t-shirts Jeff
and I always think gumbo sounds like
David Taylor he's like being
condescending to you Taylor
yes I'm fine I guarantee you either cart
just puts on being a cousin yeah like
that's him trying we should not be a
kind would we ain't Bernie you want to
smoke a joy I know could we sell that
t-shirt yeah I think I bet you his I bet
you he has an estate that that owns
Ocean imagism
absolutely hunters no way this guy's an
institution I want that on a t-shirt
dude so badly dude that could be oh it's
great news like that Muhammad Ali where
he has his arm you know after he knocks
out whoever but his arm was only there
for like a split second so he was making
the peace symbol but he why with the
middle finger first and somebody caught
the Impala or they just or they just
stopped it off Photoshop that I didn't
see but I'll take that picture oh dude I
thought it was a legit that's great dude
I had so much respect for Martin Luther
King it just went down a little bit just
this guy loved to [ __ ] though love the
[ __ ] he does Oh cheated on his wife all
the time good uh well just gives you
like a little puzzle mean you're [ __ ]
bad guy love Samoan porn
man he's making white chicks back when
that could get them killed think about
that [ __ ] you're like I love black [ __ ]
so much that I could die for this yeah
that was love of the love of the game as
love of the game look at him like I'm
begging some other chicks right now
right now he's looking at some titty to
the side he's tell you that white woman
here oh man what a [ __ ] deer what do
you create please welcome Kevin Christie
to walk in the studio oh [ __ ]
Kevin how are you what are you doing
here with your hard shirt on which is
great dude can you do a portrait of all
just think about this just real quick
just think about this Dale Earnhardt was
alive in 2001
what happened 2001 9/11 just think about
that just think and then later he
crashed oh maybe he had something think
about this we kill him we were all alive
in 2001 and then what happened 9/11
that's proof right there that's proof
right there we don't want he said
sensitive to him when he's a real
American
Earnhardt died what year did he write
after 9/11 right after this - sure he
died he was it he was in the seventh
building hey did you drive in here with
your your Chevy
yeah your lumina they learn our division
I needed the front-wheel drive so you
got to go in reverse you are you ready
sure that we're getting a new t-shirt
yeah I would wear that are you friends
with Neal Brennan like close he's
writing for Ellen I hear huh mg am I not
supposed to say that out loud on a
podcast that's unbelief oh yeah he has a
bit about it going to her house what's
her house like it's a she gotten to the
point of crazy well she's got like a
hotel her gates open up like - vagina
lips and you just drive through there it
queefs her gate squeeze yeah welcome to
Ellen's and we lost Kevin
part of Evans trying to work in
commercials makes it happen
Ellen runs Hollywood looking at is that
not a demon child right there look at
that I am a haunted puppet you know dude
Ellen looks like she eats [ __ ] angry
anybody else like she's just like eats
it like she actually chews on it like
she'll chew on the lip a little bit dude
oh man hey to help your baby would you
would you become Ellen's girlfriend like
if Alan Blevins left her and she's like
I want to date you would you day Ellen
to help your baby have a better life and
I think Jeff would be on board
he'd be like absolutely do this we need
that it would be that big of a deal yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah we got read em we
gotta get in oh it's right here don't
worry about but I mean it's not out
you're not on it yeah I'm doing business
dog business okay ah yeah so here's my
thing guys you could have made money off
Ryan winning or throwing cool yeah there
was there was a betting limit because I
had thought about just going putting
like 40 grand from s think they didn't
think about that they do business
returning these dick Genomics would
never do that
ha ha these well-crafted dick
multi-layered dick joke comics would
never do that
we literally rang Kevin Christie off
he's like oh okay I'm about him though
that he's like he knows like dude he
works he is out he's very funny
he knows when to get out he is great
he's way more conservative than I
thought like his dad was like super
military and all this stuff and like we
were we were a tie game like look at
we're talking about her buddies right in
the other room like he died like dude I
love that guy um but he was talking
about how um we were watching some kids
sing the national anthem and he's and
they were just like trying to like
[ __ ] hip-hop it up you know like
he's like my father fought for that
national anthem and they're [ __ ]
disgracing Christ dude you know what
dude
did you see dr. Drew sing the national
anthem at Ellis mania no oh yeah dude
yeah do you see me taking me did it show
me taking a knee I think they put I
think they cut it out
I took a near API view if they shot him
forward you will see me taking a knee
fighting for Ellis is a little talking
and then they bring out dr. Drew and I
take a knee and I think Mike Catherwood
got a little mad he's like what you need
during dr. drew I love my castle the
host of love line just love Ellis that
was all there Mike Catherwood on it all
the time yeah they're they're tight he's
a great in it I thought he was gonna
fight him fight he fought one year yeah
yeah I would kick cope duct-taped
together
oh dude that's Oh they were on the same
team yeah I know how many people do you
think we're there it's after this I
don't know it says it holds three to
four thousand before that so I don't do
you think there was 3,000 show me cuz
they did from that angle I'm in the back
on the stripper pole taking a knee
what's more patriotic than taking the
knee didn't Star Spangled Banner got a
stripper pole he's a classically trained
opera sir and he's a great guy like he's
super shredded for his age dude
absolutely that guy power [ __ ] young
chicks as any married she watches and
yeah the dr. Drew episode yeah I don't
how many I couldn't see my glasses on it
was pretty the bottom was all full for
the mic there was juice at 3,000 I think
there is a lease a thousand there's a
thousand oh guy it ain't you can't see
anything what are you talking at the
lookout black it is are those not
prescription glasses array those are 40
40 teacher I think it's a conspiracy
that they put
dummies up there to make it look like
the top row is fill
what's going on we're just gone behind
the cameras if anyone knows that sample
was walking around the whole venue no
thank you every shot that we've seen of
you you're doing this dude here you
might know what so what's Wolfe knife
this is just an Ellis it's a company
that just designs designer knife okay
and he's the he own it I think he's
either super sponsored by or he owns it
okay
they just make like different knives
yeah we can cuz they're like Wolfe knife
meetings they have like Wolfe knife
Wednesday like I don't know what it was
and everyone there was wolf night oh
yeah rich like a wolf night guy like you
just love a wolf night and you and your
grandpa and the topless [ __ ]
bartender no one died in World War two I
mean every bucket died of cancer now
that's like clothes and [ __ ] that was my
future father-in-law Oh perfect like it
was so random I got there like hey I'm
due to joke about your [ __ ]
after-party but it was just like dude
there's tits up there you want to go I'm
like your father I was there yeah yeah
who ordered the tits who ordered the one
topless chick who any of my brother you
know my brother-in-law the big yeah the
guy who's got 90 guns no though that's
my brother okay well I and my boy yeah
both of them okay but he's the big like
ogre dudes yeah six four yeah 260 yeah
hi
so that's his buddy is the guy that
ordered the sweet and the topless and
like had a full bar going and she was
doing any bartending she was just
talking to somebody as grandpa like this
is the most unusual after party I've
ever been to
were you there with Sean Patton showed
up I know yeah I was there that he's
funny he's [ __ ] yeah and guys if you
ever want to see Sean Patton live you
should just go to see geek that's right
see geek my friend see Kiki what are we
doing I thought you had a new read Oh
anyway you just send it to both of us
okay
guys tomorrow night I yeah tomorrow
night
I am farmtruck crossing off the last the
last band that I've always wanted to see
that never got to see you
Allison James oh well yeah but there's
no Layne Staley dude but I don't care
I'll take it at this point no who's the
frontman now it's like some
light-skinned black guy I think it's
Martin Luther King we're not sure when
Scott what's his name from Stone Temple
Pilots was he it was no he was they
basically took Guns and Roses took Scott
Weiland and made Velvet Revolver that
they were great I saw them live they
were great I saw them live at the whisky
gogo which is a big rock club but a
small venue for a been like that it was
one of the best concerts I mean these
got you're like okay these guys are rock
gods man I [ __ ] crush I saw them too
when I was valeting at this company they
were doing a fashion show as one of
their first shows together and the dude
who owned it may or may not have been
gay and he's like do you want to come
watch it with me I was like who said I
didn't I didn't want to be forced to do
what I wanted to be under my own [ __ ]
point
odd choice point rock what did your
family think of Ellis mania they shot I
didn't tell my mom until the next day
and my mom said you're so soon after you
fought yeah oh that's hilarious cuz
you're close with your mom so it's so
funny she don't know she guys so she
goes I was googling Ryan O'Neal mixed
martial arts nothing was coming up and I
knew something was wrong
she called me permanent damage so my
brother was there and my sister showed
up surprised and then my other sister
showed up also so can we all miss there
used to like you know they were scared
can we call speedrun is easy can anyone
get Steven's easy on the line yeah we
have to get him along yoking in your car
and you didn't respond to me so he was
the guy he was with uh-oh dude he yeah
he seemed was wasted when I left because
he had the crowd the slight cross I yeah
you know when you're not looking you and
he was talking about how he wouldn't be
afraid to fight me in the ring because I
would gasp he's that I I fight you toy
and he's like looking at me
he's not it's like he's looking like
five feet behind me as he talks to me
literally kicked the dressing-room door
open where I was he goes oh look here's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] like that drunk
intensity that he has so he came I don't
know what time you guys all by the way
when we left when we left at 6:30 in the
morning Sean Payton was still drinking
in the same clothes at the bar so you
guys napped a little bit I judge enough
he came in and then just got up and just
started packing like he's like oh [ __ ]
she's dead let's go let's go it was
Tracy's birthday yeah that's why I won
because Jeb texted me was like why are
you puking in Sam's card he's like first
of all it's my car yeah like Sam's
driving and I rallied he's like I drunk
all night and still celebrated like
Malibu at noon that's really impressive
yeah well that's what have been puking
what yeah he'll call he said I own Eli
gotta miss your wedding so I had to show
up for the fight
oh it's you're really missing the one
day do all he says as it as of right now
yeah he's like a 2 week that's so funny
like it's like but this is cool right
like thank you I said he's like Tracy's
pissed I go Tracy's invited we're
inviting Tracy yeah she could still go
yeah
so so yeah so man guys football is back
and C geek is the smartest easiest way
to get tickets every game all season
long whether you're searching for
last-minute deals planning a night out
or need to find the perfect gift seeking
helps you find the best seats at the
best prices fully guaranteed there's
nothing quite like being there in person
and see geek will get you closer for a
great value get ya get the app on your
phone yeah and that's the best way to do
it I mean you can always go to their
website but get the app on the phone
wherever you are you can find out what
is playing around you you want to see a
concert you want to go see a stand-up
comedy you want to see you want to go to
that new LA Stadium which is going to be
badass when it opens that's
gonna be cool dude it looks really cool
come be badass you think they're gonna
sell it out yeah yeah the first one at
least for sure did you go to the Rams
games when it was at the Coliseum I went
to a couple if they were like 40 percent
capacity
yeah they're pretty packed now now there
we are you know it's gonna match our
jerseys Nick it is they'll have a hard
time yeah they're [ __ ] but the thing
is people wouldn't will want to go to
that just to check out the stadium
whether you like the team or not they
should do right now is go hey Chargers
Raiders please
switched cities that'll be better for
everybody yeah yeah so anyway seeking is
it's time to make your buy ticket buying
experience easier than ever by searching
multiple ticket sites and grading every
ticket by value SeatGeek helps you
immediately identify best seats that fit
your budget plus every purchase is fully
guaranteed so you can shop for tickets
on sea geek with confidence and it
doesn't end with sports
CQG has plenty of tickets to concerts
comedy and theater plays theaters
standup i've bought tickets off you so I
got my Elson chains I'm so excited where
they plan the Palladium nope nobody's
with me on now now best of all our
listeners Jason's fight nannies Johnny's
myself and the Jew you are listeners and
you guys get $20 off your first seeking
purchase I use a code punch door all you
got to do punch on today the promo code
hunch wrong for $20 off your first Sikhi
purchase sounds super easy what do I
have to do again go down can you repeat
that use the promo code seeking and get
that twice without seeking punch oh yeah
punch honk use the promo code I just did
it I just said I want to sit next to the
same triple-a at Allison change
boom boom I got tickets right next - man
behind the stupid box I'm so excited -
when is it um this what what is it wins
the show tomorrow oh [ __ ] okay
tonight's comedy care
tomorrow is Ellison jihad do you have
one of those passes where you just go
back to I'm going to sandwiches yeah see
[ __ ] sandwich free for all
yeah that's what I'm gonna do dude oh
look at that or their ticket this is
this all sold out I would feel like this
would be like this I don't think it's
sold out usually they like to brag about
it
yeah on um on the market I don't think
it says sold up so wait is it all
original members except the lead saying
yeah who died of heroin okay yeah
it's gonna be awesome I'm so excited it
would just be me and old white guys and
Mexicans that's the new lead singer like
that guy is that the guy from extreme
yeah no I'll do yeah that's a wait yeah
I forgot that they had like a black eye
in yeah look how progressive I am I'm
going to see black rock stars Thank You
Johnny
it looks so light skini must be militant
oh yeah the Brits Bryant Gumbel's cousin
that's right yeah yeah is that an afro
or is that like a perm no that's like
old guy here trying to look young yeah
that's like yeah that's like a 50 cool
after every song he's like moving on I
know and the very next member
Bonnie can he make singing this song
yeah yeah I know
I mean how does he eat yeah so sneaky
thank you that guy's such as I just
every time I watch and some now what
band is this wait wait wait normal name
is that the same guy yeah he's in two
bands well something tells me Alison
Shay's they pulled him them what do you
use no or tell me he's on an hourly way
try he's like okay guys here's your
10,000 your 10,000 yeah here's your 7/5
actually I had an hour and a half of
overtime this week that you didn't
factor in time and a half's I think my
HR rep yeah is there any band you guys
haven't seen it you'd love to see I've
never seen Radiohead I saw them open
four REM in the 90s that's unbelievable
God did you get an AIDS test I saw I saw
REM at the heart of the ball
I saw Wilco open for aria oh that's a
good yeah that was great
you know one of the best concerts I ever
went to INXS right before he [ __ ]
hung himself jerking off in a small
venue I think was the was it the parrot
or the bog pair gone ballroom Aragon oh
my god in Chicago yeah yeah the Aragon
Ballroom and then do didn't they were
like a stadium band that was playing a
[ __ ] small venue and they just
crushed just crushed dog I did seen the
Spice Girls yet you wanna be my lover
you gotta get with my friend we and my
brother are gonna go see Backstreet Boys
in Vegas in February it's not wrong that
do they have a residency yeah guess who
else has a residency front street boys
that's plagued everybody let's say name
a comic do you think has a residency in
baby John capper ill oh yes I saw it's
so interesting
yeah baby use her friends have a place
of the stratosphere they had to use two
billboards you can't you couldn't knock
him out because you couldn't get his
head to move on that neck yeah oh my god
he's yeah he's got to show up there at
the Harris and he does Thursday Friday
Saturday so he said oh so he's not even
on the road so he's a dick does he live
there now yeah no [ __ ] yeah damn that's
interesting writers you make offs on the
way he moved to Vegas yeah did he really
who did earn some yeah no I didn't move
to Vegas no he moved to uh Cleveland do
Ohio yeah oh do you really yeah you know
what though dude I get that like I'm
looking to get off that's wise Harvick
I'm look I'm do they have kids I want to
spend half the year and half the year on
a farm in Indiana where I'm just [ __ ]
got big [ __ ] work in like just working
yeah
he wants to be collecting guns yeah I
would do that
once you move to Vegas you come work on
the I'm down bro
my old thing well that was tassel corn
all [ __ ] summer that was the big job
and it was knee-high by the fourth of
July [ __ ] course that's hard work am
Balin Hey
yeah did you bet dude all the time
bailed Hey - I was slave labor Wars
listen you [ __ ] retards I would like
to be here Monday Tuesday in the rest of
week in Vegas in a house you like Vegas
that much yeah I do I really like Vegas
I like the people there like perfect
like blue-collar scumbags you know
they're like everybody I like in LA that
used to live here has all pretty much
moved in Caporal Oh all moved to Las
Vegas right I like cap he just went nuts
at the end I love I would love to have a
conversation with him I don't have any
problem but he did offer [ __ ] it right I
just went nuts
and [ __ ] on our heads like he's [ __ ]
on everybody because he didn't want to
be like honest about how he treated
everybody back in the day yeah which was
he got a [ __ ] development deal and he
just went nuts and he started like
calling his line like who got where on
the lineup and it's like dude you did
all of that why are you acting like you
didn't do that if you just said hey guys
sorry for our actor don't be like all
cool man yeah dude I mean like as the
comedy store grows and changes and gets
weird or whatever happens over there you
always like to see the Oh like Vicki
barb relax back you know because she's
doing great on like yeah uh-huh
America's Got Talent it's fun to [ __ ]
see Cynthia Levins back yeah okay yeah
yeah so we got a couple things we gotta
do is Steve gonna call in all right so
the one thing we got to talk about is he
just lost a major bet oh yeah and the
second thing we got to do is figure out
this [ __ ] fantasy league oh yeah who
we picking guys well here's what we know
are in the three of us all right
the Commish guys did we do bet the
asagna the Commish
we got to do a C key guys ticketing is
so crazy right now these days huh
tickets I want to see Alice in Chains ah
the champ will be back got it one is
that the name of lead singer the guy
that won t Dobbs Commissioner yeah three
of us and the guide is gonna tell his
kid Santa doesn't exist we have a guy
that's going to record telling his
six-year-old that Santa doesn't exist
it's so funny yeah find out sometime a
six-year-old asked me yesterday if Santa
was real and I said yeah of course he's
like oh I thought you'd tell me the
truth because my parents won't and he
was like obviously no it's like I know
parents just come down to the stairs at
the night and put presents and I was
like that's not true well you don't want
it you don't want to be that one either
no he's like Candace told me exactly
that's what L [ __ ] sad broken has a
great bit about that about how you don't
want to be the first parent to tell them
that doesn't exist one two no no in the
class weirdo in like sixth grade that's
like no yeah there was kids who were
like 12 and 13 who still believed in it
yeah well that's Indiana that's your
gradient askew on a curve right yeah we
all have autism from round up probably
yeah right what's round up on everything
no [ __ ] what are we talking about how
rent is easy lost a bet oh yeah we
started that and then you want no cast
about the fella we're gonna put the guy
in his go tells kids Sam does exist
because we're cold the Commish Michael
Chiklis yeah Michael Chiklis what the
tattoo you guys are awful
yeah buddy yeah another tattoo right no
yes every year yes add something for
what [ __ ]
Oh Corrine I don't remember what it is
it's uh it's [ __ ] boy for life you got
tattooed boy for life lifetime
membership yes all you have to do is put
a heart around it yeah is that good I
say heart but a heart the heart shot
going to add something to it the heart
should be made out of two penises that
are touching in the tip I'm not gonna
say penises because I don't know what
profession he's in if I say penises yeah
let's [ __ ] boy fertilizes that make a
heart around it I may be once - here's
what most cubes I say and come coming
out of it okay Oh Judy's gotta say hey
tattoo what's up [ __ ] boy for life
Matthew are you there what up [ __ ] boy
Matt you know you have to add something
to this tattoo and it's gotta be two
penises they look like a heart I don't
know but I'm not going penises
yes within reason you're too reasonable
I would be like no you guys I'm in you
know a weirdest cat ever Disney cartoons
nothing creepy about that a circle
around it with a with a slash through so
it's like no [ __ ] boy eventually maybe
now maybe next season I know I won a
heart yeah I think you're just harder
haptic I'm not gonna make him color it
could just be like a rare thing guys are
letting them off too easy I think this
guy would do the P Dudus we're letting
him do easy that's true that is the
hardest part after this it's all [ __ ]
gravy doesn't he sound like Josh Martin
Josh Martin yeah wait let me hear you
pronounce a few words with w's and ours
what do you guys want
so I say he has to do a heart around
yeah I just say you just put a heart
around the [ __ ] blows air oh no maybe
we could do that next year you know we
got your bit right the heart and an
arrow through the heart I can do the
heart okay era arrow heart with an arrow
sure yeah the arrow like crosses it out
it makes it look like I'm not a football
well no you oh then this guy foresees
like
boy for sure no the arrow goes through
the heart so you only see part of an
arrow going in and part of the arrow
coming out yes they'll cross through it
okay I like the cupid like to keep it
yeah yeah yes all right all right all
right you're in
alright you're in do that you got
centers your hand now if you have a dog
humping the heart just a quick reminder
this is happy in a fantasy football hey
Aaron [ __ ] you and your Midwest values I
love it all in the tempo hi I need to
get will for the [ __ ] off win win should
we do how many do we have one two three
we have four spots left okay so when
what they went to the draft what day is
the drought of town for the next like
four days oh boy cancel your vacation
we'll figure out the draft
maybe next Wednesday and by then you'll
figure out the remaining people it'll
have to be by Wednesday the latest yes
cuz footballs the next day I like that
always day whatwhat is Wednesday what
day is that
baby it's Wednesday okay okay we got we
have our other drop so should we do
Monday day monday monday is the
Commodore I think no I thought that was
on Wednesday September 3rd Oh September
3rd is Monday so let's do the 5th can we
do the fifth sure September 5th can we
get it yeah let's do September 5th are
you available September fin everybody
must confirm and check in that day if
they do not check in we replace them
with somebody can we do that ok no is
this good for Matt Matt you good with
that anyway you've got to have the tap
by that yeah all right perfect
what time but touching video time we
want wrap yeah all about what Matt wants
I don't know we got see what times are
available on the espn2 do it we'll get T
Dobbs to tell everybody
Matt you
like a tattoo guy that you go to like or
you just go to some red one I just
random people that's a lot less
embarrassing you know what right
that's so funny all right bro you're in
thanks for calling and thanks for
getting a tat welcome back in the league
brother welcome back dude
welcome back we also have a guy who bet
45 dollars on Ryan O'Neal and we said we
would pick someone there okay we got ya
yeah his name is Ola Tosun hello
telephone he's you guys know him he met
all of us okay
he was one of the black guys yeah oh
yeah we gotta have a black guy and he
gave us a baby again do we gotta like
baseball I mean we have to let Negroes
in at some point okay so let's go we're
halitosis with them I just wrote down
black I pretty sure I'll remember who it
is meet girls join fantasy league start
on my league the college can pick the
players too so what are we up to how
many more did you get Stevie hey hi oh
look who's here hey wait are you keeping
you keep are you throwing up right now
while you're driving or can you be you
got a minute okay how did I keep hearing
AGP rallies you make it to Malibu I made
it to Malibu
he quit threat and everything were you
hungover oh my god I Daniel day-lewis
could not have acted the performance I
put on this was your phantom threat well
did I saw we were beautiful restaurant
in Malibu during this brunch and I am
fighting back bar that I just I'm
smiling and nodding but Wes I had aa but
I really did a good job you have kid no
idea that even Bronco Sam put that
that is proof that you are a great actor
I you know it's so funny because I saw
Sam's post you're going down the car
freeways blowing up left and right and
then I saw your post happy birthday to
the sweetest love of my life and I'm
like oh he's in so much trouble today
he's a dead man he's like the perfect
dismount like I didn't I was I was
attentive during the dinner I got there
in the lunch I didn't like get on my
phone and stuff like that yeah gave her
the post at the end I wrote a card oh
great you slept a whole I thought I
wrote I thought you robbed a casino the
way you wanted to get out of that hotel
like I thought oh dude he just killed a
hooker or he robbed the [ __ ] casino
and we gotta get out of town now she's
like dude I just woke up and you're like
[ __ ] shoving clothes in bag you're
like go we gotta go we gotta [ __ ] go
dude I'm like what the [ __ ] just
happened and then I'm like okay well we
said we're gonna leave at 7:00 I'm gonna
try to jerk off in a hotel because you
know it's a nice hotel so I'm about to
start jerking off so they get a [ __ ]
text dude I'm in the car let's go I'm
like [ __ ] we gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here so I ran down I'm like dude you
okay and we just took off set the whole
time I Drive the win okay cuz I'm the
transporter dawg
you make people sick with your [ __ ] you
I Drive the [ __ ] win
he's sleeping the whole time literally a
half an hour till we're about to get to
his house he wakes up you gotta get it
out of the system before you walk in the
door man guys I hate to cut you short
Louie yep oh yeah you lost what's the
news you lost I know I lost it's gonna
be bad but we gotta write your gay porn
it's gonna be everyone can take turns at
pump we're gonna punch it up I already
got your character named Rena Rena Rena
sleazy in walks Rena smiling I love you
buddy
what no I should be a Rena on his knees
II
do great job yeah dude let's get all of
young the young black Hollywood door
guys antigen yeah a blow bang for who
opens ran it on his knees ease walks in
already on his knees I'll see those
[ __ ] carts you roll under a car with
hey well he thinks he was a good actor
pretending like he wasn't hung over on
his wife's birthday wait till he acts a
lot much he loves [ __ ] drinking come
should figure out what we have access to
where we could shoot this at like an
auto repair store yeah close down water
park but I'll do it all here I think
magical would like it yeah I'm just
gonna say it green spring green
screening yeah yeah like they're [ __ ]
it like a [ __ ] Jurassic world or
something you know you'd see el mágico
up there covering his kids eye who looks
like a little mini album like covering
up a side what uh what if he's like a
paleontologist who gets transported it's
all caveman [ __ ] yeah okay bet he's
doctor right now on his knees Johnny
you're most likely gonna be editing this
they got one of those club dude Dan Neal
Brennan's are going to direct it yeah
yeah yeah now the thing is I believe
that the rules said of course no
penetration but he does get to have a
make-out oh dude even better how about
there the cavemen are going to roast him
like a pig but instead of the spicket
it's two [ __ ] when I asked where the
mouth and he's on a rotisserie yeah in
in them then they'll put in some special
effects of a fire cooking them
underneath yeah we can do all that in
post that's what you always
just put this [ __ ] in your mouth will do
the rest oh well yeah we'll make you
drink coming toast don't worry about
that guys
oh don't worry we're gonna vote we'll
put that in don't worry about that what
handle ahead a lot of this brain down in
life it's wonderful Oh also what is
hanging out and a dinosaur's [ __ ]
another dinosaur Eddie pulls out just
blows his load at RIT is easy yeah it's
just like a [ __ ] Linus or t-rex comb
like an elephant these ladies are coming
a little too quickly for you Ryan it's
almost like you have these in [ __ ] I'm
ready to roll with any sort of porno
okay so so we're at what five now five
people on this show five people on this
thing do we have anybody else no we only
need three we only need three more okay
so we need three more yeah now Casper
wants out he wants out because he's from
that [ __ ] country of [ __ ] Momo's
right oh my god somebody else to run his
new podcast is not Josh Martin all sorts
of views by of trip same Triple E here
Josh Martin else's oh that's right
you'll literally get descriptive without
gay porn but you won't make you won't
say mom Owens art my father is just hate
do we got anyone else calling in yeah
feel free to call and tell us why you
think we have two we have two spots few
spots yeah so let us know why you think
do we have any women on in this is the
tattoo the craziest thing anyone's done
to get into the sun's gonna tell the
kids Santa guy drink urine last year he
drank up like a lot of urine you're like
no no you break it up urine he's like no
no I'm gonna keep going with this if
anybody I'm also willing to accept if
anybody will kill themselves or walk
into a mall and shoot up a mall if
you'll shoot up a mall you can get
JC bow our that of Jason Tebow he
accepts all liabilities we are not on
that level
do not shoot up a mall not sure anybody
shoot up anything that is that why is
that guy Martin Luther King looking
sedans right there that's the guy it's
in our league now all right
congratulations black community what
year that's weird that he found like two
80s cars [ __ ] right that's obviously an
older picture ID what is he like 60
years old yeah 30 an 85
hey that's one of our many many
african-american fans take it easy bro I
think he is he a fan of ours yeah well
yeah I saw him he was in the crowd
course he's in a league we wouldn't mind
many many black friends what Michael
Robertson says that he will either drink
a gallon of Flint water or get a hot dog
tattoo on it oh no the Flint water has
been proven that doesn't even have lead
that would do anything okay so sorry
seems quite flammable
Spira see drinking water saying that
that it didn't have the level of lead in
there wasn't as bad as they said it was
what this is what the news reports have
been saying and you gotta trust the news
Hey ah what is what is the what is the
UH you think get a hot dog tattoo on his
ass he says he will yeah Mike can we
pick what the tattoo is a hot dog well I
would like it to be the buns on each
cheek and so it looks like his ass crack
is why doesn't he get his cheeks like a
Venus flytrap that's that's too much
Oh or could we get a hot dog running
into his [ __ ] what about a naked hot
dog putting a bun on because it's
running I'm not I'm late for late for
work yeah like all right I'm willing to
if he'll get a tattoo of a hot dog on
his [ __ ] he is in but we need to have
our on his ass but we need to have you
guys already have
tattoo you got to go with a different
guy here but dude who's getting a hot
dog and he shouldn't have the [ __ ]
fight nanny's face on the hot dog do
that or Johnny she got to either do
fight nannies or Johnny's face I'm the
hot dog about to run into your butthole
are you if he's in on that he's good but
we need to have a backup in case he
chickens biting the head off like a dead
pigeon
whoa no animals hurt no it's dead I like
that we see dead pigeons like at the
park can I go yeah you would get so many
diseases what are ya like light swallow
no you gotta eat roadkill whatever kind
of you got a dead raccoon on the side of
the road whatever ya nadedrekt I should
put them in people's mailboxes
but I hate it in my neighborhood I would
scoop it up with a shovel and I put it
in a mailbox at a people that I hated in
my neighborhood brother shot a dead
rabbit and then he had a stop like fruit
the guy's [ __ ] open window see it's
rough away what's wrong with us
Indiana goddamn ah and then I would just
wait I would wait and I'd sit there and
watch the Murrays open up the mailbox
and look for mail but enough it's just a
[ __ ] stinky dead raccoon I don't know
why nobody's calling in on this I mean
this is a [ __ ] tradition like no
other
dude it's hard to top a guy getting a
[ __ ] tattoo on his ass wait [ __ ] boy
for life it doesn't have to be top you
just got to some creeks just something
that you want in yeah like eat a dead
squirrel or you like be a chick with big
tits and send the pictures yeah doubt
that's happening there was a guy that
last year Americans TD sent us photos of
his wife yeah so weird like we're too
short
we're fur coat go into like a PETA
organization that's for directions I
don't wear or just shoot up a mall
[Laughter]
I'm not with this I'm not either but by
the way the Madden curse has really
taken a new [ __ ] turn as well that
they [ __ ] you know that someone always
gets injured every time there's a new
maddened that means that a guy that I
playing mad and Jason's [ __ ] working
new jokes oh thanks I just dawned on me
that's a good bit though dude I like
that ah so who we do what are we gonna
do with this we need two more
72 marbles and then we need silicon Bowl
oh I'm sorry we do have a guy who says
that he will trim his pubes put them in
a tub of Greek yogurt and then that
yogurt in the knife in the microwave and
then eat that oh he's a ginger by the
way yeah oh yeah do it go for it
he's making it cottage cheese yeah okay
you're in if it's cottage cheese all
right how do you guys feel about that I
know I don't want to microwave it I
don't think microwaving to make it
better or worse I'll do the hair in the
microwave yeah it'll get a little burn
sort of oh yeah oh you'll have that
sweet smell oh yeah a little ketchup in
there make it look like it's his his
pubes now is he microwaved the cottage
cheese - or does he microwave the hair
throw it in the Chi Chi's spinning it up
throw some ketchup on it scalding hot
cottage cheese in August microwave I
don't think she's gross do you wanna
microwave because she's better than
holding hot cottage cheese in his face
which one do you think it should be what
do you think
uh what about sriracha in the eyes it's
like being maced yeah whoa Oh what
allows yeah what about somebody pepper
sprays themselves oh good one but you
have to make sure that it's really
pepper spray yeah it's hard to prove
like is that pepper spray hand written
on what does somebody cut off a finger
haha how about someone has sex with
their dog no Danish Ananya yeah I'd like
to see that I did a radio show in
Florida and they were saying that
they're finding that kids have watched
so much porn there now watching like dog
porn this guy who says he will
fight baby what if we what if we get a
fight out what if we tattoo fight baby
no like either like a oh that would not
we don't even post pictures of her face
so how's this person gonna see her face
it would you know a limb with your okay
I'm saying no I fight baby gets a tattoo
she could be in the league
she doesn't want in the league how do
you know if you asked her a fight baby a
teardrop tattoo like she's done hard
time like like your vagina was
challenged by the way how disappointing
is that when you see a super hot chick
[ __ ] a dog like what is going on here
or a horse I'm just like if you let him
do that I'm just blown away on a super
hot chick [ __ ] a dog dude I'm blown
away by the production value of
bestiality porn now like they've really
like a budget I feel a need kid
yeah they got lighting they got craft
services everybody's eating it's
actually gone next level it's pretty
amazing kibble I'm 500 pounds I will
fight O'Neal go I'm your biggest fan
seriously I'm 500 pounds I will fight
O'Neal who loses to a Puerto Rican in a
fair fight Wow I'm gonna be like the
rest of your life everybody let's go big
that guy is I feel like we got to do an
intervention on in 500 pounds dude your
hearts gonna explode bro yeah which
one's 500 pounds that guy at the gym oh
that guy [ __ ] yeah dude you gotta
lose weight man you're too big these
guys from Clovis too I'm up in Clovis a
lot yeah you guys should fly my lady we
bought the family there yeah you should
fight them see we've got some that can't
be done in a week like this guy says
he'll go kneel outside Soldier Field in
a Colin Kaepernick Jersey this guy will
call in every week taking a [ __ ]
obviously we already have somebody Phil
is that Ari
exactly Matthew Devlin wants to call in
no that's that's that's the guy tattoo
guy [ __ ] boy for life okay [ __ ] boys and
I will go that's like this guy he said
you'll grow a mullet you know what are
we doing uh take too long right I can't
do it before the draft I mean at this
point
would love to see a guy taking me and
enough [ __ ] kaepernick Jersey lore is
that where's a good place to do that the
big thing if he could think of a place
he could do it before the draft that
would be kind of provocative and all is
that it's the Chicago WNBA team still
going well they got bounced Cubs game go
to Cubs killer like like church or
something I don't know we're go to a
Cubs game doesn't have to be during a
national anthem right tell them to go to
the local and ra office and take a knee
like American Legion something like a
Veterans Administration maybe the
Veterans Hospital I we don't want our
friends to get shot o of our friends
what if he gave a dildo to like a Toys
for Tots 10 to 20 I'm in your league
you're in the league for the rest of
your life since you got nothing else to
do since you're rotting in jail and
getting your ask anybody been watching I
am a killer yes i watch some of it's a
little creepy it's super creepy Ryan
Ryan your tinfoil hat co-host says he'll
let nanny pepper spray and hazing but
Ryan doesn't know sports but I do it hey
wait is this not to get in the league as
a goof sidenote
guys we would be amateur one of the
stroke at least would be a mistake if we
didn't send a big shout-out to our good
friend Mickey golf or the Blin back in
the winner's circle so congrats to you
I sang his walkout song - baby Barb and
she loved it and she was smiling so big
and she really liked I don't know if you
know this but she does not look at the
TV but for a fighting MMA fighter in the
make and that's when I started having
contractions was on a fight night it's
so funny she's always like like dead
stares at the TV she's gonna get knocked
up by a fighter you know I hope it's
good be by Grandma over here raising
kid by herself as your daughter
stripping at Spearmint Rhino you really
liked Mickey's walk out so I was like
this is our friend I told her the whole
story and we also see the argon J's as
name gone jaegun got the guy who won the
whole thing
can we see his oh yeah do patreon house
patreon do it
how's that patreon doing it's good we
can one thing at a time right okay what
are you the fight night you want yeah I
want to see the the main card fight
Mickey galls was 69 seconds get it you
lazy you go gay - yeah I saw someone
tweeted at us that's the most
punch-drunk thing ever for him to win
yeah I saw that too this time I gate she
didn't go to war he [ __ ] he's
realizing like that level you can't do
that and it's like you're fighting the
best out there this guy was talking so
much yeah they were really hyping him up
on UFC Fight Night 2 they were all about
weight we only eyes were in it now he
has two losses but he only had one loss
crying take a better shot than that guy
I could take that guy's punch I told you
dude my brain doesn't know it look at
that dude this guy almost hurt himself
dude he's so [ __ ] athletic these guys
are do backflips off of a [ __ ] like
seven foot cage good for him dude I love
look at that dude I like that guy damn I
like its Fighting's gonna be a legend
hamster you know they're talking about
Eddie Alvarez going back to Bellator
it's like why why steadily Alvarez have
to go back to Bellator it is my theory
Ryan O'Neal that I'd like to tell you
that I don't know if anyone believes me
I think the belt or and UFC are working
together I think the UFC sends just good
enough names where they're not depleting
their division but a name enough to get
people excited about Bellator fight to
have a legit competition so the fighters
can't say they have a monopoly I could I
could I could buy into that I could buy
into that just like letting guys go just
good enough not good not to take a title
like Roy McDonald's probably the best
fighter they ever let go yeah he was a
top [ __ ] three guy yeah but he
couldn't get over the hump he could
never be
- champ but he's a big enough name and
sent over there going all dude they got
some real fighters over there now and
Eddie Alvarez
okay he's like a little past his prime
now but he was a champion they're like
why would we let next champ go
yeah I'm he's always in the mix he's
someone you could put on a fight and
they're like okay this is a good fighter
theory I could get behind yeah me too
this one's not that crazy
I I think they're doing it on purpose Oh
like they get rid like let's be honest
like why we got rid of Goldberg right
has anybody they replace Goldberg with
that great that they have to get rid of
Goldberg I mean damn annek or whatever
his name is the guy John the comic yeah
Breivik Daniel Cormier but he's not so
great that it's like the new fight
nights like this one that was on like
Paul Felder and whoever else is with him
fighter right yeah but I can't stand
when they do it I like want to watch it
on mute I think they're so bad at it no
good Goldberg man it was the better yes
entertaining it's not entertaining Ivy's
in trouble I think they're worth seven
billion Mason dad when we've had one
good fight card in a while that people
bought like they're getting back John
Jones I think very soon and they're
getting back the girl McGregor that's
big for them well thanks to pay per view
so shitty it's like the for the main
five fights are women and no one likes
that I do like FEMA but would you buy a
pay-per-view like with that maybe cyborg
know that tyron woodley dare until one
and then it's like no one else and
there's like three women fights I think
on the main too many well it's it's you
know here it is it's like it's like
comedy clubs where they're like you got
to fill the room but you're gonna make
way more money than me you filled the
[ __ ] room and let me do the stand-up
that's what the UFC does they don't do
anything really the push fighters as
hard as they should you seen ideas
coming out like you know they under
promote him and then Bruce Buffer fired
back and he's basically [ __ ] you shut
your [ __ ] mouth yeah the next quick
tweet was like all due respect because
he gifted I
was a you bow down to them [ __ ] you yeah
dude and like I mean that guy he said
you're on the US he's nuts
yeah I'm if there's anyone I'm in that
sack it's [ __ ] yeah it's the buff
loves the boss goes nuts acts right and
I get it dude he's got a great life and
a living he's never gonna have to worry
about paying his bills after being to U
of C forever I [ __ ] get that I don't
know why like like Ronda Rousey doesn't
join the UFC Union you literally have
nothing to lose and it will help your
shitty legacy that anybody who really
fouls fighting knows you were just at
the right time like if you were dropped
in right now the number 10 person would
[ __ ] you up and that's my honest opinion
these girls are probably true it evolved
man yeah you know it's like yeah she's
in the vein of horse grace
Chuck Liddell and [ __ ] Bruce Buffer
what the [ __ ] get off the UFC nuts
you're bowing down right now telling me
to bow down [ __ ] that you keep bowing
down I bow down to no one ever for all
the money you're in the wrong door for
so many extra letters English you ever
watch your daughter yeah you know who
else also does that Pauly Shore and I
need some wee Andrew Dice Clay top tweet
where was he
can see can you tell us where he was Oh
with all due respect Pauly Shores uh
that's so disrespectful Oh
shorts tweets looks like he tweets with
boxing gloves on no for Twitter to get
off its [ __ ] high horse and get an
edit button and you could play at it
under there so people know this tweet
was edited it's it's literally then just
trying to be [ __ ] or look how cool we
are go [ __ ] yourself
I like Pauly I've always liked I love
them a great guy we love me we're just
talking about Heather we do love me we
do love not a criticism one has a purse
you should've gotten the Diaz brothers
to help you fight
if you're there and [ __ ] out poor we
cannot dog do you see that the new
iPhone sucks and then flip off emoji
said [ __ ] you iPhone see the new iPhones
do so they all suck dude your new iPhone
middle finger what's the other full the
Android even collects more of your day
oh dude he say he must be Sactown guy on
those nuts you have see that's not a sax
out at all I love that guy
yeah dude he's a true he this guy's a
[ __ ] American treasure who Nick yeah
and any yeah both they both would say
fight they're both you look bad like I'm
all the time to get in fight man they
could have been making money yeah I know
I mean we got million right I know but
they're gonna be out of fight they're
gonna be rusty wait what's that with GSP
cheated when he fought my brother he was
on steroids I mean I do we all agree
that that's not out of the realm that
GSP would cheat yeah I don't think so
but they you had me to he's like so
geeky and plus they test him so I didn't
take roids yeah how about the fact that
they you sada has only tested John Jones
once in these two years I mean smart you
know if you want him to come back to
fight I don't I guarantee you that he's
not gonna hardly get dude are you reason
wait cutting is the biggest issue as
everyone's been talking about dude how
good do the Raiders look man I think he
switches you know we're done I don't
think I don't think you're gonna be
disappointed
oh [ __ ] you dude and your [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you and your new
iPhone here iPhone here iPhone why don't
you get off the Raiders nuts yeah
Raiders nutsack that's what I'm talking
dude you guys got some big acquisitions
the Cubs huh I'm just trying to every
school
within the last five said last 30
seconds cubs gobs are good
yeah the Cubs got what's-his-face from
the national lab killer I can't believe
they got him I can't believe they got
him I'm so obsessed because he sucks
dude
about those whites oh listen to the
Cardinal guy bitching about the [ __ ]
Cubs what hottest team in bait no the
Hasim baseball is Tampa the hottest team
in baseball is Tampa let's get back to
this porno stuff yeah red is easy oh
here we go here we go come on oh oh hi
hello hey boys hello who's this hello
man port it was popping this Oh cousin
Jeb I heard him
Oh cousin Jeb what's up are you do you
want in this week he said what like that
we tried to fit that in the last 30
seconds of the show to all sports and a
phone call Lincoln goes on his phone you
got it you got to take it girl you got
to take cousin Jeff when you take a
cousin Jeb guys feel free to subscribe
to our patreon we just last one we put
up was a the fight companion so you can
listen to all of us yeah so we're all on
this one yep
yeah called we called Weiser first one
like eight months right yeah yeah we
called Sammy and rent is easy while they
were at the fight we called fight nanny
and Jeff after the fight well the
alcohol on the phone call with Stephen
is easy could could you smell he was
nowhere to be found it was just you
he was already cut loose by the time we
called he was priority up at the [ __ ]
tit place topless bartender no no we
have a giant fan on our tea a day as a
fan of punch strong that's the VIP guy
at sapphires and I couldn't find it
in following my phone I wanted to go ask
you what that is what it's a strip club
yeah I was like I hate strip clubs and
then you go there you're like you just
become a monkey I'm not a big strip club
I'm not either
I'll take you there you'll be a strip
you go the Indiana strip clubs yeah
that's why you're not a strip club guy
they'll [ __ ] Street yeah yeah look at
this look at this guy
what what I Lucifer
I'll listen to a full episode of same
spots about to block him are you guys
enjoying it oh that was really funny you
don't have a profile for ya [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright guys this has been one of the
best podcast is I've ever done a test is
oh by the way listen to the Danish and
O'Neill pod pleased every Monday if you
want to hear about hot [ __ ]
bestiality porn - never one beats the
alley podcast
hey you they critique their favorite
[ __ ] porno they just sent one of our
episodes to outer space
welcome alien oh that's great alright
dude
I appreciate coming on you were great
Friday you fought hard Jason Tebow about
it yeah I'm proud of my man good job
good job
I know that was hard Johnny [ __ ] off and
yeah [ __ ] stuffed-crust kiss it all
right take care guys bye